en direct dans cette édition christophe
prudhomme porte parole de l'association
des médecins urgentistes de france et
urgentiste au samu de bobigny bonjour
merci de répondre à nos questions ce
matin après avoir été mis de côté lors
des premiers mois de la crise sanitaire
le port du masque est devenu obligatoire
dans de nombreuses villes de france on
vient de le dire le conseil d'état se
prononce aujourd'hui quel est votre avis
sur la question de ce port du masque
généralisée écoutez toute cette
polémique le ton du masque est
contre-productive à partir du moment où
on n'a pas fait le gouvernement n'est
pas capable d'avoir un discours clair
qui permettent de convaincre la
population d'adopter des mesures ils
paraissent cohérentes et bien on ne
n'arrive pas à ce que ce port de masques
soit accepté par tout le monde tente il
n'apparaît pas justifiée
comprenez bien que vous voyez sur vos
plateaux vous invitez donc vos invités
alors que vous êtes à moins de deux
mètres ne porte pas de masque et
certains préfèrent encore du nas côté
français on fait tout parce qu'il peut
justement nommée voyez je pars d'une
manière générale je regarde la télé vous
avez des plateaux télé avec cinq six
personnes personne ne porte le masque et
certains préfets oblige les joggeurs à
porter le masque
où est la logique vous comprenez bien
que depuis maintenant plusieurs semaines
et plusieurs mois
il aurait été beaucoup plus simple de
dire que le port du masque est
obligatoire en tout cas fortement
conseillé quand on est dans un milieu où
on ne peut pas respecter les mesures
barrières c'est à dire un mètre à un
mètre cinquante de distance moi je peux
vous dire que quand les gens sont
convaincus ils portent le masque on
seine saint denis je prends tramway pour
aller à l'hôpital
je peux vous dire dans le tramway nous
nous sommes serrés comme des sardines en
seine saint denis tout le monde porte le
masque 100 % des personnes en tramway
porte le masque parce qu'ils sont
convaincus qu'il faut porter une masse
ils sont d'autant plus convaincu qu'au
plus fort de l'épidémie mon département
a été fortement impactée par la
mortalité puisque nous étions ce que
l'on appelle les premiers de cordée
c'est à dire des gens qui ont continué à
être
yep et donc ont pris des risques oh la
la plus forte de l'épidémie justement
commencé j'ai commencé nous amener là où
vous travaillez on parle d'un regain de
l'épidémie est ce que vous le constatez
vous sur sur le terrain le ministre de
la santé libéraux prévoient une hausse 1
d admission en réanimation dans les 15
prochains jours
est-ce que vous êtes prêts écoutez une
hausse des admissions oui nous avons une
légère pause d admission qu était tout à
fait prévisible il faut comprendre que
tant que nous n'aurons pas un vaccin
eh bien il faudra vivre avec ce virus
pendant les deux à trois années qui
viennent
qui plus est là pour rebondir quand même
sur cette histoire des masques il est
clair que si la même politique est
adoptée sur les vaccins on risque
d'avoir une forte réticence de la
population à la vaccination
si le langage n'est pas clair de la part
du gouvernement en ce qui concerne
l'épidémie
écoutez les chiffres
cette communication alarmiste du
gouvernement est aussi contre-productive
aujourd'hui effectivement il y à une
hausse de la positivité
mais vous avez bien vu et votre
reportage de montrer que on ne sait pas
trop qui est testé où il ya des délais
pour obtenir les résultats on a une
petite augmentation d'activité à
l'hôpital il est clair que il faut
surtout surveiller ce nombre de malades
hospitalisés je préférerais mois que la
communication journalières soit centrée
autour des causes d'hospitalisation et
pas du lait aux de la positivité les
tests pour l'instant c'est euros c'est
tout à fait modérées il est clair que si
effectivement le l'étions confrontée à
un nombre de malades plus important
l'état de nos hôpitaux n'en déplaise au
ministre n'est pas meilleur n'est pas
meilleur qu'au moment où nous avons subi
le pic de l'épidémie
donc je dois dire que dans quinze jours
vous ne serez pas prêt si jamais il ya
un repos épidémique important on sera
mieux armée pourquoi parce que les
traitements les traitements au regard de
l'expérience
les traitements que du groupe
posée aux malades se sont fortement
améliorés et nous savons que nous
pouvons éviter l'intubation d'un nombre
de malades important c'est à dire des
soins très lourd en réanimation est donc
ce qui permet de diminuer la durée
d'hospitalisation des patients en
réanimation mais ce sont les seuls
progrès que nous avons faits nous
n'avons toujours pas plus de lits de
réanimation de leur animation
supplémentaire ne soit pas capable
d'ouvrir c'est du bricolage il faut
savoir aujourd'hui que pour les 5500
livre animations qui sont actuellement
ouverts nous manquons de 1000 médecins
pour les faire fonctionner correctement
ne manquons de personnel voilà donc ça
c'est une donnée incontournable et la
situation des hôpitaux la situation des
personnels ne s'est pas améliorée parce
que le ministre nous a octroyé
simplement une augmentation de salaire
qui est toujours bonne à prendre on
regarde la faiblesse des salaires des
hospitaliers mais ce que nous demandions
la première revendication était les
embauches de personnel et ce personnel
ces embauches
nous les attendons toujours les files
d'attentes devant les laboratoires ça
vous évoque quoi et bien une préparation
et une désorganisation de notre système
de santé vous savez cette dualité entre
la ville le système libéral les hôpitaux
publics
cette manque de coordination entre la
ville et l'hôpital va nous la payons
aujourd'hui voilà alors chacun essaye de
faire au mieux alors on voit que un
certain nombre d'élus locaux s'agite
pour mettre en place des détentes qui
permettent des tests sans rendez vous
enfin voilà il faut tester les bonnes
personnes au bon endroit c'est pasche la
course à l'échalote entre les politiques
voyez c'est comme sur le masque alors
tel maire va prendre l'arrêté rond le
préfet qu'il ya une surenchère la part
du préfet de la rs c'est la même chose
au niveau des collectivités locales dont
il ya besoin d'une stratégie qui soit
cohérente organisée etc les tests soient
ciblés dans les zones les plus à risque
et voilà on a une carte épidémiologique
que l'on connaît il ya des zones où
effectivement le virus circule mais il
est clair qu'à partir du moment où nous
avons des capacités de test limitée et
bien il possible
ces tests parce que ouvrir des tests
gratuits que l'on met en place sous les
tentes dans sur les grandes places
publiques
quand les résultats sont deux les quatre
à cinq jours après vous savez
l'efficacité de la mesure est voisine de
zéro par contre il faudrait un peu plus
communiquer sur le fait que quand une
personne a été en contact avec quelqu'un
qui est contaminée eh bien il faudrait
que cette personne
au moindre doute et bien puisse s'isoler
en attendant de pouvoir faire un test
est d'avoir le résultat parce qu'il est
clair que c'est là que se produisent les
contaminations
merci christophe prudhomme d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le porte parole de
l'association des médecins urgentistes
de france la mifa